I do not want to go skiing I do not want
to go to a beer garden it is not fun for
me to go look at a museum I am NOT
interested in watching Netflix I am NOT
interested
you got your perspective
[Music]
so when you're when you're working with
family how do you balance the love that
you guys have for each other with you
know getting tough feedback on time
comedies
yeah I'm believe it's the most typical
thing you know business is business and
Families family and those are two you
know blood is thicker than water
you know you know these are unbelievably
difficult things to me it's like a 50.0
50.1 it's not even 5149 that i like to
throw around family businesses are more
50.1 to 49.9 than where you have to be
all about the family as you can imagine
if you actually understand what I just
said it leads to a lot of tough tough
conversations and a lot of conflicts and
a lot of being very careful and
threading the needle very carefully at
the end of the day for me personally I
was always in a position in the family
business where I was making the core
operational decisions so I had to put
the logo ahead of anything else in the
Mike Rao I was willing to shut down the
[ __ ] business if I thought it was
gonna undermine my family relationship
of my brother and my dad but on a
day-to-day basis in the micro I always
pushed for the thing that I thought was
best for the business got it think you
have what it takes to make it to the top
it's time to make your pitch step in and
step up because your window of
opportunity isn't the only thing that's
closing I'm so good at it I'm so good at
it
this is real quick because there's a lot
of bubbling up of like Gary you're
pushing people to work too hard and all
this stuff and I'm watching it I'm like
I love one elitists who work their faces
off to make a bunch of money then tell
everybody else not to work hard so so so
to me if you love what you're doing and
you're happy and you're mentally and
physically healthy do you I'm not
judging anybody about doing anything but
it's all about self-awareness and could
and putting a framework around where you
don't keep up with the Joneses I know
you get a lot of criticism for it I get
a lot of criticism for how many hours I
work and I'm like mother [ __ ] are you
not listening like here's the punchline
I work that hard because I'm having fun
happy I don't want to go skiing
[ __ ] I do not want to go seeing I do
not want to go to a beer garden it is
not fun for me to go look at a museum I
am NOT interested in watching Netflix I
am NOT interested that doesn't mean that
I think everybody else should do that I
think and I've said consistently
self-awareness happiness I've said it a
million [ __ ] times do I believe in
hustle yes I do
I like work ethic it's controllable do I
want that to put you into depression or
health scares yeah of course not dick
face but don't sit on a pedestal after
you [ __ ] more [ __ ] for 15 years and
then tell all these kids that they
should have work/life balance
you [ __ ] elitist
once you understand that in your life
[ __ ] you're either going to be
chasing money or you're gonna be chasing
fulfillment and nary the twain shall
meet
when you chase fulfilment you may also
build a massive [ __ ] company I'm
gonna do both I always say and I'm
making the rules then I'm gonna be the
best entrepreneur because I'm gonna make
the most money and have the most impact
on other entrepreneurs
I only talk what I live hate when people
work 11 years on their startup work
their faces off
I watched them grind and then they hit
and then they're sitting on money and
they're not part of their life and then
the advice they're giving isn't what
they lived
I want to hear four people publicly that
made 47 thousand a year their whole life
and her happiest [ __ ] goes talked about
that I'm talking about happiness people
are using mental health as a weapon to
make themselves look good
just like nonprofits you might be
tricking the 99 percent but you're not
tricking the one-percent partner
[Music]